romane et lillois n'auront elles leurs
résultats du bac demain
le ministre de l'éducation nationale la
sueur mais les notes affichées ne seront
pas forcément celle des épreuves passées
en juin avec la grève tout ça va
forcément on sait pas à quoi s'attendre
c'est pas si on sera touchée par rapport
à notre académie donc on attend et voilà
nous enfin on a travaillé pour avoir le
bec et enfin c'était quand même
difficile une épreuve 4h ou 5h et puis
on a passé du temps à réviser et tout ça
et puis qui gardent les notes pour qu'au
final
enfin on n'est rien quoi ça se fait pas
je trouve que on devrait les avoir quand
même car en cas de copie retenu par les
correcteurs grévistes
on ne lâche heures il ya c'est la
moyenne de l'ensemble des notes de
l'année qui sera comptabilisé une
décision qui attise encore plus la
colère des professeurs dire je vais
prendre les notes de contrôle continu
s'est sacrifié des élèves parce que nous
notre job en année s'est formée et au
moment du bac c'est d'évaluer des
compétences acquises pendant deux ans et
pas du tout la même chose ça nous paraît
quasiment illégale et surtout injuste à
dire que ça nous montre bien que le
ministre est prêt à tout pour faire
passer sa réforme en force et surtout
pas à nous écouter comme c'est ce qu'on
demande quand même depuis début du
mouvement et ce qu ils nous refusent
catégorie notes du bac moyenne de
l'année
l'important pour les parents d'élèves et
d'avoir des résultats nécessaires à
l'inscription dans le supérieur
maintenant comme elles seront transmises
instantanément il faut tous les élèves
puissent être évaluée avec des notes
pleines sinon on aurait vu des élèves
qui se serait trouvée affectée
simplement non pas parce qu'ils étaient
les premiers sur l'affectation mais ce
dont les notes seraient arrivés en
intégralité les premiers dans l'académie
de dijon près de 16000 lycéens attendent
leurs résultats